NIKOLA KAMBUROV: Hi everyone.
In this video, we're
going to explore briefly
the concept of a
vector subspace.
This is the problem
we're going to do.
We're given these four
different subsets of R^3,
and we are asked to figure out
which of these is, in fact,
a subspace.
So I'll give you a few moments
to try to do this on your own,
and then please come back to
see whether you were right.
So hi again.
So before we start,
let's briefly recall
what a vector subspace is.
Well vector subspace, of
course, it's a subset.
In this case, a subset of R^3.
But it behaves like a
vector space itself,
meaning that if we take
linear combination of elements
in the subset, what we get is
still something in that subset.
And in class, Professor
Strang showed you
a few specific
examples of subspaces,
which are related to matrices.
One of them was the
null space of a matrix,
all the vectors that
the matrix sends to 0,
and the column space
of a matrix, which
is the span of the
column of a matrix.
So let's see if we can
apply what we've learned
in lecture to our problem.
Number one: we are given
a linear equation relation
between b_1, b_2, and b_3.
Once we have something
linear-- this is a philosophy
that you'll learn
in this class--
we can always write this
as a matrix equation.
So in particular, b_1 plus
b_2 minus b_3 equals 0,
we can just write
it as the matrix 1,
1, negative 1, times
[b 1, b 2,  b 3] equal to 0.
So therefore, b_1,
b_2, and b_3 precisely
describe the null space
of 1, 1 negative 1.
And thus, what we are
given in the first question
is a subspace.
What about the second one?
Again, we are given the
relation between b_1, b_2, b_3.
but it's not linear.
b_3 is the product
of b_1 and b_2.
So right, your guts
tell you that this
shouldn't be a vector space.
But we need to prove why.
Well, see that the vector [1, 1,
1] is inside this subset,
because the third entry is
the product-- 1 is the product
1 and 1.
If the subset were
a subspace itself,
then we would have 2,
2, and 2 in it as well.
Right, because any multiple
of a vector in the subspace
is inside the subspace.
But is [2, 2, 2] described
by this equation?
Well no, because
the third entry, 2,
is not equal to 2 times 2.
So the example in number
2 is not a subspace.
Let's try 3.
And first-- so we are given--
so the subset in question 3
is given as the linear span of
these two vectors, [1, 0, -1]
and [1, 0, 1].
Plus the vector [1, 0, 0].
So let's think about
this geometrically.
We know that the linear span
of two linear independent
vectors-- and these
are obviously linearly
independent-- is a plane in R^3.
So we have the plane,
and we add a vector
to the point on this plane.
So what if the vector
were lying on the plane?
Well we're not going
to change the plane.
We're still going to
remain in the plane.
What I'm hinting at is
the following thing.
That, in fact, [1, 0, 0] is a
linear combination of [1, 0,
-1] and [1, 0, 1], and
it's fairly obvious
to see which linear combination
of these two vectors it is.
It's 1/2 [1, 0, -1] plus
1/2 times [1, 0, 1].
So we can write the
whole relation here
in the following way.
[b 1, b 2, b 3] is
[1, 0, 0], which
we can write this, plus c_1
[1,  0, -1], and c_2 [1 0, 1].
Let me continue this here.
So b_1, b_2, and
b_3 is precisely
c_1 plus 1/2 of [1, 0, -1]
plus c_2 plus 1/2 of [1, 0, 1].
So indeed, the points
b_1, b_2, and b_3
are described by the linear
span [1, 0, -1] and [1, 0, 1].
So it is a vector
subspace itself.
And finally, let's
look at number 4.
So we have a similar situation.
I mean, it's almost
the same situation.
We again have the linear span
of precisely the same vectors
as in question 3.
But this time we add the
vector [0, 1, 0] to them.
Now, [0, 1, 0] is not in the
span of these two vectors.
So the argument that we just
showed for 3 doesn't work.
But what we know
about vector subspaces
is the following thing.
I follows almost
trivially from the axioms
that 0 needs to be inside
the subset in order
for it to be a subspace.
It's a necessary condition.
Well is 0 inside this subset?
Meaning can we find coefficients
c_1 and c_2, plus [0, 1, 0]
to equal zero vector?
And the answer is no.
And why is this?
There's a very
easy way to see it.
Well we just look at the
second entry of the vectors,
and we see that any multiple--
so the linear span of these two
vectors will have as
its second entry 0.
And when we add it to 1, we can
never get a zero entry here.
So the subset in 4
is not a subspace.
So I hope this was useful in
just getting an intuition which
subsets of R^3 are subspaces.
I'll see you guys later.